this episode is brought to you by
curiosity stream a subscription
streaming service that offers over 2000
documentaries and nonfiction titles
unlimited access starting at just $2.99
a month from 30 days for free if you
sign up a curiosity stream calm /by
graphics with the code biographic smore
about them in a bit there are few
historical figures whose name evokes
more dreads than that of Blackbeard the
pirate undoubtedly the most infamous man
to emerge down at the Golden Age of
piracy of the late 17th and early 18th
century
black bears has far transcended all of
his cohorts and has become not only an
archetype for the villainous pirate
captain but a pop-culture figure who is
still present in our movies TV shows
books and video games there were other
more successful pirates Baha Lemieux
Roberts aka a Black Bart may have been
the most triumphant Corsair from the
Golden Age of piracy capturing an
estimated 400 ships during his career
Henry every dubbed the king of all
Pirates took one massive prize and
managed to disappear forever actually
getting to enjoy the riches that he had
plundered a female pirate who
prowled the south china sea commanded a
giant army of tens of thousands of men
and yet it is black t it that everyone
knows and everyone fears but what was it
about this larger-than-life figure that
made him stand head and shoulders above
his contemporaries well today we try to
find that out as we explore the life of
the dreadful pirate Blackbeard
[Music]
right off the bat there is a problem
with trying to tell the story of
Blackbeard one which is shared with
pretty much every other pirate of his
time and that's a lack of contemporary
sources Blackbeard might be the most
famous Corsair in history but we know
shockingly little about his life before
he raised the black flag the main source
we have for black birds life and indeed
for many of his ilk is a book originally
published in 1724 by one captain charles
johnson it went by several very very
long names as it was reprinted in
multiple editions but it is typically
known as a general history of the
pirates it's a fascinating read and it
certainly has a lot of juicy stories but
the way it presents its characters in a
somewhat mythical way makes historians
think it might contain its fair share of
fans not just facts fittingly even the
author is a mystery to us so little is
known of Captain Charles Johnson that
people have usually assumed it is a
pseudonym since 1932 when the idea was
first proposed by writer John Robert
Moore many people have been convinced
that Charles Johnson was an alias of
Daniel Defoe the English author best
known for his novel Robinson Crusoe or
it is possible that Charles Johnson
never really existed and was simply an
amalgam of anonymous authors who all
contributed different biographies given
that Blackbeard was in his late 30s and
early 40s when he died in 1718 he must
have been born sometime around 1680
presumably in Bristol they knees most
often during his pirate career was
Edward Teach or sometimes fetch with
various spellings of each incarnation
truth be told pirates often used aliases
so we cannot even say with certainty
that either one of these was his real
name it is a bit of relevant though
because everyone just came to know him
by the sobriquet Blackbeard at that time
Bristol was a major international port
particularly active in the slave trade
across the Atlantic therefore it is
almost certain that each started serving
aboard a ship from an early age and some
historians believe that he came from a
respectable family and had a good
education according to Captain Johnson
before turning to piracy
teach operated as a privateer out of
Jamaica
during the anglo-french war of the early
18th century which itself was part of
the larger conflict known as the war of
Spanish Succession specifically teach
may have been active in the American
theater known as Queen Anne's war where
British colonists forced the French and
the Spanish this is bolstered by the
fact that when he finally captained his
own ship teach renamed it to the Queen
Anne's Revenge in case you ever wondered
what the difference between a pirate and
a privateer was we might as well clear
that up now while a pirate was a
criminal who operated mostly on a
free-for-all basis and attacked whatever
ship caught his fancy a privateer was
more like a private contractor under the
service of his government during wartime
he received a commission known as a
letter of marque and was only allowed to
target ships belonging to the enemy and
he had to give a percentage of the
spoils to the government the problem was
that once the war was over privateers
were supposed to stop attacking ships
however by that time most of them had
already developed a bit of a taste risk
and they didn't really have any other
marketable skills so many of them just
decided to become pirates while we're at
it let's cover two more similar terms
Corsair ins Buccaneer a Corsair was an
English term used to refer to foreign
privateers and it was intended as an
insult meanwhile Buccaneers were a
specific group of pirates from the
Caribbean who started out as hunters on
islands such as Tortuga and Hispaniola
they preyed on boar and cattle and sold
the smoked meat to passing ships and in
French the meat was known as beyond
butcher knee because they were tough
skilled hunters the Buccaneers soon
realized that it was easier for them to
simply attack the ships which docked on
their islands and soon enough they
gained a fearsome reputation and were in
demand by all pirate and privateer ships
the story of Blackbeard starts in
earnest in 1716 when he took up piracy
you might be surprised to learn that his
career only lasted a little over two
years but it was enough for his infamy
to spread and grow to the point where he
is still a fearsome character since 300
years later teach was somewhat
successful as a privateer captain
Johnson mentioned this he often
distinguished himself for his uncommon
boldness and personal courage but but
specified that he was never given
command of a ship then he became faced
with the same problem as all other
privateers in 1713 following the signing
of the Treaty of all tracks to the war
ended teach no longer had the backing of
the British government prey on Spanish
and French ships so inevitably he termed
piracy sometime between 1713 and 1716
Edward Teach left Jamaica for New
Providence and islands which proved to
be an ideal headquarters for pirates
although that once had colonists it had
been abandoned following numerous
Spanish and French attacks during the
war even though they were badly damaged
the island still had multiple structures
including a fort so the Pirates didn't
have to start from scratch whilst in New
Providence teeps joined the crew of
another famed pirate of that time
Captain Benjamin hornigold hornigold's
notoriety would increase in just a
couple of years when he would accept a
pardon from the British government and
become a pirate hunter tasked with
bringing down the same men he once
sailed with Blackbeard included for the
time being however the two had a strong
relationship
hornigold had been impressed with
teachers nautical skills and gave him
his first commands as of a ship they
captured it was only a sloop of war
which was a small ship with only two or
three masts but it was a start
[Music]
the beginning of 1717 was a fruitful
period for teach alongside hornigold he
sailed to mainland America around the
coast of Virginia and together they took
several prizes first there was a ship
coming in from Havana
which had a hundred and twenty barrels
of flour then another sloop from Bermuda
which was carrying wine and lastly a
ship traveling from Madeira in Portugal
to South Carolina after they had enough
prowling the waters off the American
coast
the Pirates headed back to the West
Indies in the fall in November they
captured a French gentleman called la
Concorde which had left nons and was
headed for the island of Martinique
again even was a large cargo ship
intended specifically for the transport
of slaves according to a report given by
the ship's French captain Piett Oh c'est
la Concorde at 16 cannons and
seventy-five crewmen and was carrying
over 500 slaves and around 20 pounds of
gold dust however their voyage across
the Atlantic was long and arduous and by
the time they encountered pirates they
had already lost 16 crewmen and 61
slaves not to mention the fact that
another 36 crewmen were stricken ill
with scurvy and dysentery when they met
teach about a hundred miles away from
Martinique the French had little
resistance to offer especially this the
two pirate ships had a combined might of
a hundred and fifty men and 20 cannons
after two volleys fired at la concorde
captain to say surrendered the vessel
afterwards the pirate sailed the ships
to the nearby island of Bequia where
they dropped almost everyone on the
shore a few of the French crewmen joined
up with the Pirates voluntarily while
several useful members such as surgeons
carpenters and a cook were press-ganged
into service teach preferred this new
large ship to his old tiny sloop so he
left that one behind with the French
sailors and took back on court as the
French had little say in the matter so
they accepted the new vessel which they
renamed more very contra or bad
encounter as for the Concord with
hornigold's permission teach captain
Dudesons turned it into his flagship
renaming it the Queen Anne's Revenge we
already mentioned that this name came
from teach serving in Queen Anne's war
but it is also possible that he was a
Jacobite person who wanted to restore
the House of Stuart at the throne of
Great Britain instead of the house of
a nova queen ant was the last monarch
from the House of Stuart who had passed
away in 1714 now just before we continue
with black bids journey today let me
tell you a bit about today's sponsor
curiosity stream curiosity stream is a
subscription streaming service that
offers over 2000 documentaries and
nonfiction titles from some of the
world's best filmmakers including
exclusive originals if you're looking
for a specific recommendation from me on
that platform
well what ties well into today's video
would be a series called deep time
history and especially the second
episode of that series which is all
about the age of exploration something
you'll probably be into if you're
enjoying this video now full disclosure
I haven't actually watched that series
yet but two things one if it's anything
like anything else on curiosity stream
it's gonna deliver and so I had a quick
flick through a quick watch of a bit of
it and it does look really great just as
good as all the other stuff on their
curiosity streams available on loads of
different platforms is also available
worldwide you can get unlimited access
starting at just $2.99 a month and for
you guys the first 30 days are
completely free if you sign up at
curiosity stream com forward slash buyer
graphics and use the code biographic s--
all one word lowercase no quotes during
the signup process that's a great way to
support this joke and keep us making
more videos and I couldn't think of a
better fit for sponsorship and so let's
get back to Blackbeard
now teach add a ship that matched his
ambitions and he was ready for the world
to get to know and fear the name black
did he spend the next year prowling up
and down the islands of the Caribbean
taking prizes wherever possible this
included a large vessel called the great
Allan which the Pirates plundered and
destroyed as well as a sloop called the
adventure which Blackbeard captained
added to his fleet captained by his
sailing master a pirate called Israel
hands near Barbados the Queen Anne's
Revenge engaged in a naval battle with a
powerful man of war named the HMS
Scarborough even though the other ship
was bombed with 30 cannons the Queen
Anne's Revenge proved to be more than a
match for instance after several hours
of fighting the Scarborough disengaged
and retreated to Barbados Benjamin
hornigold and his ship the Ranger were
present for some of the plunders it's
not exactly clear when he and Blackbeard
parted ways but in January 1718 he
travelled to Jamaica to accept the Kings
pardon and become a pirate hunter during
this time Blackbeard also made the
acquaintance of another closest
associate one who merits inclusion just
because he is unique in pirate lore
Steve bonnet what exactly the two met
varies based on the source some say the
teacher on a gold first ran into Barnet
while they were plundering the coast of
America while captain Johnson specified
that Blackbeard met the other pirate
captain after acquiring the Queen Anne's
Revenge
what made Steve bonnet truly special was
that he seemingly had it all yet gave it
all away to become a pirate he was a
wealthy respectable landowner with a
sugar plantation in Barbados even so he
borrowed money to buy Anne's outfit a
ship and secure a crew and then he left
his past life behind and raised the
black flag we can only speculate as to
his motivation maybe he went through an
extreme midlife crisis or maybe he was
just really really bored and wanted some
adventure contemporary accounts suggests
that bonnet suffered some discomforts he
found in the married state however
becoming a pirate just to get away from
the nagging wife seems a tad extreme to
historians who argue that bonnet may
have actually been mentally unstable
whatever the reasons Steve Bonnie became
a pirate captain even though he had no
knowledge of sailing teach picked up on
this pretty quick when the two men
he used it to his advantage in order to
add another ship to his command but it's
men were perfectly happy sailing unto
the mighty Blackbeard instead of an
inexperienced captain bonnet was
recovering from an injury and was made a
permanent guest bought the Queen Anne's
Revenge while one of teacher's men the
first mate named Richard's captain
bonnets ship the revenge of course in
this case permanent guests was just a
polite way of saying prisoner and it's
on to know what would have happened if
bonnet tried to forcefully regain
command of his ship this was never the
case however as the gentleman pirate as
he was sometimes called seemed content
sailing alongside Blackbeard and just
being along for the ride
eventually back beard fully betrayed
bonnets when the captain decided that he
had too many ships in his fleet he
strips the revenge of loot and supplies
and beached us almost marooning most of
its crew on a sandbar to his credit
bonnet did learn a thing or two about
being a pirate while sailing with teach
he was able to get the revenge seaworthy
again secured a crew and went in pursuit
of his treacherous former companion it
would have been interesting to get a
final confrontation between these two
and see who came out on top
I'll ask bonnet never met Blackbeard
again instead he was caught and arrested
and after numerous delays he was hanged
for piracy on the bright sides for busts
at least bonnets trial transcripts
became an important source for a big
chunk of Blackbeard's career
[Music]
the first half of 1718 saw Blackbeard at
the height of his power he took prize
after prize with little to no opposition
because his fleet was mighty enough that
no single ship stood a chance against
them but also because people began
hearing the name black bears
if teach was good at anything it was
cultivating a menacing reputation for
himself which sent chills down
everyone's spine and made ship captains
surrender before there was any need for
actual combat physically teach was an
imposing man he was described as being
tall with wide shoulders and obviously
had a very long dark beard he wore a
sling over both shoulders which
contained braces for six pistols that he
held across his chest like Pantelis
allegedly he was in the habit of taking
long slow burning fuses lighting them
and tucking them under his hat so that
little wisps of smoke would form around
his head giving him an otherworldly
frightening appearance curiously a
teacher also apparently liked to take
his long beard and braid it into
pigtails tied off with colored ribbons
doesn't exactly sound particularly
terrifying but I guess people were a lot
easier to scare 300 years ago whatever
he did it worked and most ships were
ready to surrender as soon as they saw
Blackbeard's flag
speaking of which well what was
Blackbeard's flag exactly well that's a
hard question to answer
there is one design which has been
associated with the pirate for a long
time it features a horn skeleton holding
an hourglass in one hand and a spear in
the other which is piercing a heart it's
an interesting design but it appears to
only be a hundred years old as it was
actually first described in a magazine
in 1912 with no evidence to suggest that
it was ever used by Blackbeard as far as
contemporary accounts are concerned
there is a single description which
appeared in a newspaper detailing an
attack by Blackbeard's fleet on a
merchant ship it mentions there were
five pirate vessels in total two of them
at black flags with deaths heads on them
while the other three had bloody Flags
going by this information it is possible
that Blackbeard used these stereotypical
skull and crossbones for his design
[Music]
in the spring of 17-18 Blackbeard had
enough of the Caribbean and sailed back
to America here besides taking a few
more prizes whenever the occasion
presented itself teach embarked on his
most brazen endeavor blockading the city
of Charlestown South Carolina today
called Charleston the Pirates boarded
and seized all of the ships that tried
to enter or leave the port one of those
vessels that Crowley contained a lot of
rich prominent Charlestown citizens who
were headed for London Blackbeard took
them as hostages and told the governor
that if it didn't meet his demands it
would send the governor all their heads
and burn down the ships that he had
seized Blackbeard's ransom demands was
rather dull but still practical he
wanted a chest full of Medicine he sent
one of the hostages mr. marks and a few
of his own men ashore and gave them two
days to return before he started cutting
up heads those days passed without
response but fortunately for everyone
involved the captain wasn't a premature
to capitate at Blackbeard delayed his
punishment long enough that marks
arrived with medicine and explains that
the reason why it took longer than
expected was because the Pirates got
drunk in the city and couldn't be found
Blackbeard was content with this
explanation and released all of his
hostages safely without their valuables
of course from there the pirate fleet
moved on to North Carolina where
something bizarre happens at Beaufort
Inlet like they had lost the Queen
Anne's Revenge
apparently the intention was to Karina's
careening is the practice of grounding a
ship intentionally at a high tide so
that during low tide you can repair or
clean the bottom of the hull that's
normally underwater however the ship
apparently went too far ashore and ran
aground into a sandbar they tried to use
one of the sloops to tell you the ship
back to water but that one run aground
as well and both sustained too much
damage to be usable again just like that
Blackbeard was left with only two scoops
this proved to be a real boon for modern
archaeologists as a search team found
the wreckage of the Queen Anne's Revenge
in 1996 and researchers have been
studying and excavating it for over two
decades
it wasn't until 2011 that it was
conclusively identified as the flagship
of Blackbeard the Pirates but it did
raise a question regarding how it got
that losing two ships while careening
would have been even using the gentlest
terms
a foolish mistake up until that point
Blackbeard had shown himself a capable
captain that is why some historians
speculate that he may have done it on
purpose in order to break up his crew
[Music]
next up teacher went to Bath North
Carolina and accepted the Kings pardon
like hornigold and many other
comrades-in-arms in an effort to curb
piracy King George the first extended a
one-time offer to pardon all pirates who
surrendered willfully with the promise
that those who didn't well they'd be
hunted down without mercy
whether Blackbeard did this because he
lost his flagship or whether he ran the
ships grounds because this was his plan
all along we can't say what we do know
is that he became close friends with the
North Carolina governor Charles Eden who
not only gave teachers pardon but also a
commission as a privateer aboard his
remaining lubes the adventure the pirate
more or less continued his plundering
ways but now he had the approval of the
governor who most likely received a cut
of the spoils Eden may have been happy
with Blackbeard prowling his waters but
the nearby governor of Virginia R
Alexander Spotswood was not some of the
captains former crew members had already
begun causing troubles in his territory
and having Blackbeard in the area
severely puts a hamper on local trade
yet little legal recourse against the
pirates but he didn't care he wanted
blank they had gone one way or another
technically sports would Commission's to
armed sleeps to go and capture teach for
several acts of piracy which he may have
committed after the cutoff date for the
pardon which was on January the 5th
however he did so knowing full well that
this would most likely lead to a battle
the virginia force was led by lieutenant
robert maynard a man described by
captain johnson as a gentleman of great
bravery and resolution on the morning of
November the 22nd 1784 two sloops
approached the adventure in the channel
leading to Ocracoke Island and engaged
it in a fight first came several volleys
of cannon fire which proved quite
destructive to Maine arts forces and
gave black did the advantage this
prompted the pirates aboard the
lieutenant's ship but unbeknownst to him
he walked into an ambush
Maynard ordered most of his men to hide
below deck and trick the Pirates into
thinking they were severely outnumbered
as soon as Blackbeard and his cohorts
were aboard the British sailors pounced
according to maintenance accounts the
fight lasted six minutes afterwards the
infamous Blackbeard lay dead after being
shot five times and cut 20 times
the surviving pirates quickly gave up
Maine uttered black bears head tied to
his ship's bow spirit while the rest of
his remains were thrown in the water
that was the end of the world's most
notorious pirate it was somewhat fitting
that Blackbeard died in battle and got
sent to Davy Jones's Locker instead of
being hanged like most of his
contemporaries if anything this violent
ends only helped increase the legend of
Blackbeard as evidenced by the fact that
it's still going strong today so I
really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe brand new videos like this
about four times per week so hit that
Bell to find out when we put out a new
video also this video is possible of
course because of curiosity stream their
link to below
thank you for watching